Come on. Game day. [can't] really [sleep] last night woke up with a brand desire to get buttershaw
[break] it a little bit of breakfast in right now that one one little walk do
[get] my day started I can show Charlie
the moment [of]
[jail] with the game
Yeah, and a nice outline. We grind we grind
Now headlights off. We still get it in your ear. [I] don't know. What's all about right beside my brother ray already get
How many here runs away from us one two three?
For more than 30 years aspiring professional athletes have ventured to Bradenton, Florida to train at IMG Academy
in
2013 the Facility which also serves as an academic institution
Fielded its first high school football team
Over the past couple of seasons the IMg academy
Ascenders have stockpiled some of the nation's top Gridiron talent the main reason why I came to be myself ready to get my body
Right and not only mentally, but physically get prepared for college and as well as academics. I mean
Academics here young [there] so many resources we have two deserted here
you know from
7:00 in the morning all the way to no 9 o'clock at night you talk about g you talking about the best preparation
Best facilities, it gives me best repair. You know for the next level facilities are second or not
I mean some [of] the federal most college campus I venture
All our coaches are full-time football coaches our train is a full-time training. We got a nutritionist full-time nutritionist
We have basically everything a top-tier college has but we're in high school because it's where you come [to] be great
It's a professional move to come here when you talk about having the best program
You know you got some of the best players in the country you know so you notice that?
It gets kind of real out [there]. You know we don't hold anything that we know we're the best competition. We're going to say no
One of the Ascenders 5-star recruits is shaped Patterson. The Nation's number one ranked high school quarterback. We've committed to ole miss
Thing about shade that stands out his ability to throw the football you know he finds windows
And you know he gets in a rhythm, but he's really hard to stop
what makes him special in my opinion is the fact that he can roll out of the pocket and
Still be just as [effective] as if he's standing in there. You know use these literally lightning in a bottle once he gets out
He gets running around
Our turn right we have to be
Great on our returns right on the holdups if I'm the l0L my I have to get the party started
Okay, [butch] [his] guy hits the gatorade containers. Okay. Get him out of there, but we're gonna return up there
Img Academy's coaching staff has a combined 28 years of professional and collegiate coaching experience
We came down and visit Img
I felt like it was a great opportunity for my kids that come in get an [opportunity] to have a great [academic] experience
Athletically prepare themselves you know lay the foundation for their lives, and you know their future me playing professional ball
You know you got the experience about being a player you inside the lines are being a coach you outside the lunch
I was fortunate enough to be at Tampa Bay starting with our head coach Tony dungy
and then going to my defensive back Coach Herman
And one of the things he would always say would be appropriate right?
Ooh, do here is [we're] trying to have the best student athlete
[I] think winning young athletes look at where I've been and that's a it's a dream a goal for a lot of them
You know I can certainly speak from experience
Knowing the challenges that I went through in [my] career and relate that to our young players having guys
Who played in the National Football League?
That can speak to the journey that it takes to get to that level having that NFL pedigree is huge. Let's go
Halo-Halo
[Ernie] Logan the Defensive Line coach
Played for nine Seasons in the NFL under Bill Belichick Tom Coughlin and Bill Parcells, Ernie
He has the presence of a defensive Lineman voice is very deep
To a boy he's a guy that our defensive line
Not only can look up to because he's played the position, but also they better get in line because when he speaks
Everybody [on] the field kid can hear him?
Tag [hey], are you serious what you think this flag football?
When his favorite word is boss this ain't no family show bones. Everything is boss honor when he's talking to you is boss
Are you [a] biscuit away?
Your biscuit away from 280 balls. I think ernie was probably using the term ball [sleigh] before [it] was really cool
Yeah, you three bills boss?
He's so [bipolar] as a defensive line [code] like here be on you one one second and then the next second
he makes you laugh with
Off-the-wall [jokes] [oh] he say something. He's a truck here. It is well good. I get off on the sidelines ball
You fine
We do that drunk
Just woke up
It's about 9 a.m.. Heading to [Walker's] a
Little bit tired this game day bag let's go
It's the third Saturday of august Img academy's first opponent American heritage the two-time reigning
Florida State champions
What you got here? [she's] [deaf]
That's what they're saying. They're saying you're not about who's about to pay for champions. Have you looked in the mirror?
Have you ever thought about everybody else's perspective?
You think they're scared that expects [to] win and they expect to keep your [tail]
full of Rich kids
spoiled Rich kids
right
That's the perception
You get everything you don't know anything
Nobody [knows], what do you?
Lose jump back. Let's get crazy. Let's play control passion win your back with your back
Heading into their preseason opener the ascenders would be without their top defensive back
LSU bound Five-star senior Savion Smith who would miss the game due to a groin injury?
atmosphere [Yama]
The lights come on the showtime, baby. They brought a flag and run through that Sonar field
on our field
They bring a flag and run through it on our field. Hey, I got listen
I swear everybody better go watch you all night. Everybody king everybody. [hey], [man]. Let's go
Don't tell me what to do
Img academy has dreams of being the best team in the nation standing in their way though American heritage the Patriots have won
two consecutive state championships, and we are underway
Scrambles left finds a wide open you baked in the end zone and American heritage is on the board. Hey
Sam American heritage Patriots with a seven nothing lead at halftime over the fable Img academy
Now then [choose] [to] play a half together now. We know
What are we about?
This is where you find out who your leaders are this is where you find out what type of team you are?
right now
one score one score
You can't tell me we don't have the guys that can take it to the house
On any given play off its defense special teams and make up that difference
We just got to do it find a way win the football
By the way win a football game
Break it down. Let's go
Roll out looking for the end zone as Patterson and he waltzes in for the first points [of] the season
You can see the [mojo] coming up a little bit here for that Img defense. We alive now, baby. We allow
be a dangerous thing when we allow
Come on the play, and it's immediately scooped up. Ooh the football [we] can reload it. Hey. It's not over
Right all right now. You told me a play
And now they're gonna throw it in a great catch mate down the sideline into the end Zone goes Brandon Johnson
So the Patriots take the lead, but it's only a six-point game almost over Bi
[and] IMg will have about 85 yards to go
Time to throw this time over the middle big time catch 420 million
And a lot of a hitch ball is Charlie
Amg academy needs to get into the end Zone
Patterson surveys the Field finds pressure
Rolls right lobs it to the end zone it is caught for the game-winning touchdown
Amg storm in the field
flag on the field
Bolded I'll move
Not anymore
Come on, man. What game on the line?
Patterson Steps up to Avoid the pressure
Just brings it down to the middle of [the] field in it
into the end Zone
What a compressive job by the American heritage Patriots [you] come here - hi
It's done a team that was ranked number one in the max [Prep] school
That's a good football team and again. This is their Super Bowl if we're not ready to execute
[oh] this approach is players all this you don't prepare of the ship
You know that's what happens another you're saying that you can give me practice [after] we [good]
You go from winning the game to all those emotions mixed emotions to losing it in just in 30 seconds, so it's definitely heartbreaking [I]
Actually didn't know what they come here, and all my thoughts. Just like everybody else you can't be
The reason we should be beat that game just show you know anybody can be beat on any day coming away from it feel like
Okay, now we can roll up our sleeves you got the kids attention. I mean no
They just didn't roll out there and all over somebody that changed everybody's mindset 18 tell from the coaching you know everybody focus dead
Talk about all the time everybody is true. You're not here. Let's just handle it first
So just understand you're going to have success guys. It's we're going to have success
How you handle success is it support is how you handle [is] [her] not [alright]. No, man. You say nothing doing this every week
Every week every week is not worth ruining. Matt. I have I to be ready everybody. [I] feel like we're the best tuna cruncher
There's no doubt about that
you